in 2010 but in the next two elections
they did not happen and calls for the
electoral laws to be amended to make it
mandatory for party leaders to take part
in televised debates it also proposes to
establish an independent debates
commission to set the rules and format
of such debates which the petition
states would take the decision-making
out of the politician and broadcasters
hands and ensure TV debates become a
regular feature of UK elections it is
worth noting that the Sky News make
debates happen campaign has received a
fair amount of cross-party support from
some prominent members of this house and
I also want to acknowledge the work that
my honourable friend a member for
Wellingborough has been carrying out in
regard to his private member's bill
which will shortly be becoming before
the house to call for to make general
elections leaders debates take place and
I'm sure we all look forward to his
contribution to this debate in due
course so happily and our whole
heartedly commend Sky News and others in
their initiative for an independent
commission on televised election debates
with my honourable friend not agree with
me that it should definitely be the case
that there should be an independent
commission rather than being left to the
prime minister of the day to be left to
their political whims as to what is in
their best interests and more and also
don't agree that maybe we should also
have deputy leaders debates within
within this whole framework as well I
think remember for his intervention he
makes a very good point which I will
come on to develop later which I think
if we are going to have regular leaders
debates and make them and formalize that
process then it is absolutely right that
that is managed by way of an independent
commission as he rightly says to take it
out of the hands of politics
and ensure that it is carried out in an
orderly and fair manner as to extending
it to deputy leaders are I'm not sure I
would go that far but I can understand I
believe that the deputy leader of his
party is is indeed keen for that to take
place
mr. Sharma we are here today to debate
having debates and but I do believe that
this petition is very timely in in
coming to this house at this time for us
to debate because there is no doubt that
the nature of politics in this country
has changed considerably in recent times
the growth of the 24-hour news cycle and
the development of social media means
that the public have come to explore
what the public have come to expect from
our political leaders has changed we now
generally expect our political leaders
to be much more visible and much more
accessible than they were in previous
generations and I believe that it is in
this context that the matter of holding
leaders debates must find its place only
last month we saw what can happen when
it was proposed for a debate to take
place between the prime minister and the
leader of the Opposition with regard to
the EU rude rule vote after various two
ins and throwings it proved very
difficult to find agreement for that
debate and it ended up not happening and
I'm not sure that what we saw take place
last month around that actually
reflected very well on our democratic
process it is also interesting and worth
noting that this petition that we are
debating here today at that time had
reached around the 60,000 signature mark
and had really slowed up in the number
of signatures that it was attracting but
then suddenly when that debate was
proposed and then failed to take place
suddenly had a sudden surge of
signatures which pushed it well over
100,000 mark very quickly and I think
that this shows both the level of
interest there is among the public for
leaders debates to be
on TV but also perhaps the level of
frustration that many people felt that
that that the toing and froing that went
on sort of horse trading that went on at
that time didn't materialize in the
debate taking place and i believe that
there is clear evidence that there is an
appetite among among a large part of the
public to see our politicians our
political leaders debate on TV hopefully
give way I agree with what happened last
month did not reflect particularly well
on politics within the British state but
one of the big problems with that
episode was that he was seen as a debate
between just to leave a party in the
Conservative Party does he agree with me
if we would have these formalized
television debates and then fatally
important for democracy that every
single party contesting in those
elections should have a part please I'm
very grateful to the Honourable member
for that intervention and I'm not at all
surprised that he makes the point that
he does I believe for obvious reasons
and I think that is one of the big
challenges and one of the questions that
would need to be addressed and rightly
that right that it be addressed by an
independent commission because I think
there is clearly a tension and a balance
that has to be struck when it comes to
leaders debate as to who is included how
many debates there are etc to make sure
that we strike the right balance between
including all political parties in that
process but also I believe meeting the
expectation that I believe a large part
of the public have which is that what
they want to see is a debate between
people who realistically are likely to
be the future prime minister and that is
one of the I think the big tensions that
leaders debates creates and would need
to be addressed by the Independent
Commission but I absolutely take onboard
the point that he is making the fact is
I believe today that fewer and fewer of
our constituents vote for us or for our
political parties or indeed our leaders
simply based on what they read in the
leaflets we put through their doors or
in the newspapers
we there have been significant changes
in the way that we all inter
with one another and how we gain the
information we need through the media as
well as through social media in order to
inform ourselves before we decide how to
vote and as I previously said there is a
very clear expectation among the public
that politicians are particularly
leaders of political parties are much
more visible and much more accessible
than they were previously the public I
believe want greater opportunities to
see the political leaders in action and
interacting with one another
in order for them to build up a more
complete picture of who they are and
what they stand for
now party leaders themselves have been
at the forefront of some of the changes
that we've seen take place that the the
election campaigns of all the main
parties now focus much more on the
leader of the party than I believe was
previously the case and very often it is
their style of leadership that is
scrutinized much more carefully
televised debates are a great
opportunity for for our political
leaders to present their case and
communicate directly with voters through
the TV screens into their living rooms
and on their smartphones it is also a
way for leaders to showcase the rigorous
debates on important national matters
that we see we see here we buy week in
Parliament but putting it into a much
more much more accessible format for the
public I will happily give away which TV
channels going to get it is that looking
for I think they are Movember for the
intervention and again he raises I
believe one of the important points that
an independent commission would need to
decide on and again that's why I believe
it's important that we have a commission
that is independent both from
politicians but also from the
broadcaster's who can manage this
process and make those sort of decisions
about who would be involved in the
debates but also who would be
broadcasting
the debates clearly from my point of
view I think it should be made as
accessible as possible and shared as
across as many broadcasters as possible
but that is something that an
independent commission I believe would
would have to manage mr. Sharma
I am a verb overview that it is probably
inevitable that debates will become a
regular feature of our elections in the
future whilst I agree probably not
everyone will welcome this I believe
that is clearly the direction of travel
that we are seeing having taken place in
2010 and being generally received well
received by the public I believe there
is now an expectation among the public
that those debates will happen regularly
and I overview that it would be better
to it to embrace just one moment just
make this point it would be better to
embrace that expectation and put a
proper process in place for those
debates to happen rather than go through
the dance we have seen recently at every
election sweeping statement which would
be interesting if he could back it up
with some evidence to prove mindful
interest clarify which statement is
you're asking me to clarify if I'm a
dramedy and my real friends claim that
the televised debates were well-received
and indeed to the extent to which they
were actually view quite interesting and
add on to the comments it is just made
if I believe remember the the figures
correctly I think though there were
somewhere around 10 million people
watched the leaders debate so the last
time in 2010 I mean I'm basing it on a
what I have perceived from the public
and I was out campaigning in that
election for someone else but clearly
when those debates took place it
certainly sparked a great deal of
interest on the doors from the voting
public but also I think just the sense
of the reaction we've see
in recent times when the debates haven't
happened I believe that the many people
have been disappointed that the debates
haven't happened I take I take his point
that views are mixed on this it isn't
the universal thing but I do believe
that as time goes on we're seeing a
general growing appetite among the
public for for these debates to take
place so I'll happily give away the
petitions committee the 2018 audit of
political engagement by the hand-start
society Society found that among
different sources of news and
information respondents use to inform
their decision making at the 2017
general election party leaders debates
and political interviews were the most
important things that they use now even
though it was an imperfect process in
2017 nevertheless voters said they were
amongst the most important to inform the
decision-making I'm grateful for that
intervention and agree I think as I said
I think there is that growing appetite
that many more voters today use
television and leaders on television
whether it is in head to head to votes
or as a or as he says in in other
formats to to help them get the
information that they want into in order
to make an informed decision I feel that
the current situation where we have
horse trading between the parties and a
sense of no one really knowing whether
debates are going to happen or not and
and and people are sort of putting out
their criteria and you know if I'm
honest and not quite sure how serious
anyone is about really wanting the
debates to take place or not I don't
think it is helpful and I don't think it
reflects well at all on our democratic
process and therefore I believe it is
probably time to embrace this and to
formalize the process so that everyone
manage this process hopefully far better
and Sky News in starting this petition
have laid out some proposals for the
Independent Commission that is being
proposed that would manage this process
that it would be established by
parliamentary statute that it would be
funded solely by agreed for
contributions from UK broadcasters I'm
sure something we would all agree on
that it should not be the taxpayer that
funds this commission or holding the
debates that it needs to be paid for by
the the broadcasters that is made up
that the the the Commission be made up
of former judges civil servants
broadcasters and other public figures
who have experience in the media and
politics that is overseen by a cross
bench peer with relevant experience and
that it works to ensure that the general
public have the opportunity to see the
leaders of the political parties who
could form a government debate each
other by including at least one
televised debate between electorally
realistic candidates for prime minister
before every general election I believe
these are sensible proposals that would
put a framework in place that I believe
would manage this process well and
ensure that it happens in an orderly and
fair manner or happily give Waggin the
basis that a televised debate is just
one means that any party or any leader
will have of communicating with voters
in the run-up direction what is so
special about this particular form of
media why would the Independent
Commission not for example have any say
over any other of their whole range of
methods in which we communicate with our
potential voters in strangers isolate
television that's the preferred as the
preferred means by which he would impose
this new regime and disregarding social
media for itself which probably reaches
although I don't know the exact figures
just as many people in just as an
effective way I wondered why we just
stick with one well I think the answer
to that the point he's making is that
this what is unique about leaders
debates and
vision it is that is where leaders the
political parties go head-to-head with
each other whereas things on social
media are primarily you know political
parties promoting their own leader or
their own policies etc rather than
having a head-to-head debate which
clearly would need to be managed and
adjudicated in a in a fair and
transparent way which i think is quite
different than political campaigning of
individual parties taking place on on
other media platforms I mean clearly we
already have party or political
broadcasts on TV which are regulated I
think this this is a sort of extension
or graph but clearly the head-to-head
nature of it means it is I think a
slightly different animal than than than
the regular campaigning that we see take
place having said that I think we are at
a point where we probably need to
embrace this as has already been
mentioned I think we do need to balance
a leadership decision to formalize
regular leaders debates with the
legitimate concerns that some have and I
think we have to acknowledge again has
already been referred to that not
necessary everyone believes that this is
a positive step to take all the right
way forward and it was interesting I
think it's worth noting that within the
run-up to this debate today the House of
Commons social media team did carry out
a very quick and unscientific survey on
the Facebook page and ask the question
should party leaders have to take part
in TV debates before a general election
and it's true to say that the response
was very very mixed and in fact more
commenters were actually opposed to
televised leaders debates than there
were in favor and many felt that TV
debates were largely about performance
and facilitated judgments being made
based on personality in appearance and
media savviness rather than on a leaders
capability to be Prime Minister some
refer
to the Americanization the British
politics and suggested that debates
could result in a more presidential
presidential style of politics which
runs contrary to our parliamentary
institution and tradition and others
pointed to the perceived gap between
politicians and voters and believe that
canvassing constitutes constituents and
other forms of direct engagement would
be far more useful so I think it would
just be right to acknowledge that you
know not everyone is entirely
enthusiastic about this but it's
something we do need to balance so I
think before pressing ahead it is
important that we weigh up these genuine
concerns and ensure that they are
reflected on before any decisions as are
taken to to progress with this I've
personally considered the pros or cons
of regular debates and as I said
although I believe it is probably
inevitable that we'll get to that point
and it's probably better to embrace it
and shape it rather than a resisting
resist it I do think there are a number
important points that do need to be
considered and I think that is important
that we do not allow leaders debates to
dominate political campaigning in
general elections debates should not
replace other forms of campaigning and
they should complement rather than
replace or dominate the election
campaign and so careful consideration
needs to be given as to how many debates
are scheduled and I think you know
probably the three we had in 2010 was
too many and certainly one or two is
where I would think this would sit
naturally
but I also believe we need to think
carefully about the timing of the
debates that it is very important one
issue that I was very much aware of in
the 2010 campaign and and the debates
that took place there was the role that
postal votes had and I believe that when
today increasing numbers of voters are
choosing to vote by post and we need to
recognize that polling day for many
millions of people
the country is not the election day it
happens several days before the actual
Election Day when their postal votes
land on their doorstep and we need to
take that into into account and I
believe that it was wrong in 2010 that
some of the debates actually happened
after the postal votes are landed and
some people had actually already voted
before all of the debates had taken
place and certainly if I was to have any
role in this I would be strongly
recommending that all leaders debate
should take place on television before
any postal votes are dispatched to
ensure that everyone and every voter has
had chance to see the televised debates
before they get the opportunity to vote
I think it would also have another
benefit if that was to be the case is
that it would free up the last couple of
weeks of the campaign and allowed those
those final two weeks of the campaign
would not then become dominated by
televised leaders debates but by the
other more traditional forms of
campaigning and I think that would be
the right thing to do I'm sure many of
us remember that David Cameron commented
when reflecting on the 2010 debates was
that it took all of the life out of the
campaign in those final weeks because it
sucked in so much energy and attention
and I think avoiding that would be very
very welcome so in closing mr. Sharma I
think that sound and informed debates
are one of the fundamental pillars of
our parliamentary democracy and it makes
sense that the voting public are able to
see our political leaders in debate in
general election campaigns we need to
accept that our political our politics
continues to change and adapt to the
changes in the way that people
communicate and inform themselves and we
should embrace this change in our
election campaigning I believe that
leaders debates are a good form
for politicians to be more accessible to
voters and should we decide to formalise
for regular leaders debates than it is
absolutely right that it is taken out of
the hands of politicians and
broadcasters and then it is put in the
hands of independent and independent
commission to manage this process and
also to reaffirm that this should be
completely funded by the broadcasters
and the bill for this should not in any
way come to rest on the taxpayer so mr.
Sharma I trust that this debate will
prove a useful opportunity to consider
this matter once again want to thank Sky
News for initiating this petition and
the 130,000 people who have signed it
and I very much look forward to the
contributions from other honourable
members here today and especially to
hearing the minister's response at the
end of the debate the question is that
this house has considered a petition
double to 857 to relating to an
independent commission on televised
election debates David do foster a new
key for really I think introducing this
petition in a particularly objective way
even though he comes to support it so I
think he covered many of the issues now
I hadn't originally intended to engage
in this debate I just wanted to make one
point but given that there is a an
opportunity I'll wrap that point into a
wider speech I mean from I say my
perspective the 2010 debate let the
genie out of the bottle and you quite
simply cannot put it back in I mean it
was bizarre that we had this particular
situation both in 2015 and in 2017 where
the prime minister of the day where
there was at least a precedent decided
that
you know that wasn't appropriate in this
particular election and I think that is
a dangerous thing I think we give Prime
Minister's far too much power so I do
think there is a need to give some
independent voice to this particular
issue and that that should not rest with
the government a day let alone in the
prime minister of the day now my main
point is that and this is the what point
are going to make that to me the
broadcasting of politics is in serious
need of an investigation I don't know if
I'm right and the minister will no doubt
put me in my place if I am wrong but
I've been quite alarmed since I've been
back in this place at the lack of
regional coverage certainly for by ITV
and I don't think they're meeting their
legal obligations I mean this is written
down in statute about the amount of
coverage there should be now this may
seem to be somewhat different as a point
from whether we have prime ministerial
debates but I find it interesting that
this was initiated by Sky who aren't so
diggers as both the BBC and ITV and I
just signed it rather disappointing that
our our mainstream media don't want to
get as much as they should do from the
political scene now I don't believe they
should show it seven o'clock peak time
I'd know there are reasons why this will
go down very badly with the wider
electorate but there are rules and
regulations on how much how much
politics should be shown both a national
level and a regional level and to my
mind that's not being adhered to and I
think that this is why this debate is
particularly oppisite at this time
because we should be able to take this
out of party politics to put into some
independent scrutiny arrangement to make
sure that politics is properly covered
in the media certainly the broadcast
media which has more control on it of
course than the the print media
so I mean my main point is that I really
hope that this is something doesn't end
with this particular prime ministerial
debate but it looks more wholeheartedly
at the way in which broadcasting is
currently being handled and making sure
that there's sufficient time is given to
it now I don't expect the minister be
there with a time you know with the
stopwatch counting every minute and
maybe she's got time to do that but I
just think we are being shortchanged and
I think that's something that we ought
to pay attention to to return to the the
main issue I mean again I I thought the
the Honourable member for kumar's in
West and South membership may have been
onto something there he may have come at
it from a different direction for me
because I'm not sure he's convinced that
this is the right way we should be
conducting our politics but certainly
you know he made the point and I think
he probably doesn't have share like my
view but he made the point that this
should be subject to you know some form
of you know wider wider scrutiny and I I
would share that and again I think it's
important that we we put that on the
record now to me these debates have to
be held in the fairest and most
impartial way as we can which again is
why it needs to be taken away for the
p.m. of the day it cannot be in any way
fairly impartial or one person gets to
decide whether they go on the television
to defend their party's policies because
that's what they are at that time
because they're not the government the
day they are a party standing for
election so I think it's right that you
should be taken away from that now we
all you know whether we like it or not
watch the US presidential debates which
are always seen to be the center point
of the whole presidential campaign now I
don't know how many votes are won or
lost by those debates I certainly know
that Richard Nixon lost but whether
there one is another matter the fact is
that that is built into their
constitution and although they have a
president and I make it very clear our
prime minute
is not a precedent and that we should
constrain the role of the Prime Minister
this is a way in which the public can at
least have some comfort that the person
that will be leading the government is
able to answer questions in a format
that they can access and they can make
their own minds up that's why it needs
to be as the Honorable gentleman first
north or nuki says it needs to be
earlier and recognized that so many
people vote for vote by post nowadays
that that has to be taken account of
when I still don't understand given that
we have a fixture in Parliament we know
when the next election should be that we
do not yet know how many days that
election campaign will be held over and
again it would be quite good to regulate
this so that we know where the debate
will be in terms of the actual time of
the campaign so this is all lay down so
candidates can prepare for it and the
public can be made aware of it whether
we have two or three or just one
television appearance again I think that
needs to be properly investigated and
certainly subject to debate in this race
which is why we're here my last point
again it really reinforces what the
Honourable gentleman said I did think
the way in which the so-called debate
within a debate on the meaningful vote
just degenerated into a forest about
whether it was going to be on BBC or ITV
walk format it was going to take who was
going to be interviewing workman's that
members of the public gonna be there as
part of the panel this doesn't help us
in this place it looks like it's always
it's our self-interest that comes to the
fore and that is something that if we
genuinely want to reach out to people we
have to accept that there have there
must be impartial rules that must be a
way in which this is done and that's why
I would hope that this Commission
doesn't just stay with the Prime
Minister deep this debate but has wider
ranging responsibilities so that we know
if it's a really crucial issue then
there are
laws by which who is going to be
interviewed how they're going to be
interviewed what time they're going to
be interviewed all that should be laid
down in advance rather than it be in a
Dutch auction of whether the leader e
opposition brings it forward or the
Prime Minister so that it looks like one
of the other is going to blink first and
that doesn't do any of us any good in
the long run so I think this has been a
useful debate I think most of us would
support this is something that has to
come back has to be properly dealt with
by Parliament and the government of the
day and just to finish I think that
eventually anything that adds to
people's interest in politics has to be
a good thing of course it has to be
properly managed and of course it has to
make sure that those who take part there
is balanced on from the different
parties and the rest of it and that will
be difficult with so many different
parties represented in this house for
example let alone perhaps in the the
wider you know in the wider world which
means that there must be a de minimis
level based on the previous general
lecture so that we know who is entitled
to take part otherwise you would get
people inventing themselves as a party
leader just to have a free hit on on the
television
so those things would have to be looked
at but the only way you can do that is
have an independent commission which has
the powers and the duty to make sure
that this is done properly and this is
done in a way in which our democracy is
in hearts rather than belittled thank
you very much mr. chairman
the Honourable member for stroud and I
agreed with virtually everything he said
and of course to follow my honourable
friend for austell a new key well I
thought move the motion in a very
reasoned way and I also thank the
petitions committee for putting on the
debate that's one of the advantages that
came out of the if you like the
expensive scandal we moved to a position
where the public can have things debated
in this house that they're interested in
and I'm delighted we've got such a
excellent Minister who's going to
respond and agree with everything I say
no we have a very good accent Minister
I'll be very interested to hear what she
has to say and also for the the shadow
minister and the spokesman for the SNP
again - excellent parliamentarians I'm
very interested in fact to hear what the
Shadow Minister says because sometime in
the future it's possible his party will
being government and how what he says
now will apply if they're in government
because there has been a problem that
people when they're in opposition have
been quite keen on TV debates but not
when they've actually got into power I'm
very grateful to Sky News of course
sorry yes I will come to that specific
point there's a very good example but I
just want to say that you know Sky News
has done something which is really
useful because it's it's got the wider
public thinking about these debates we
cannot arrange them two or three months
before a general election we have to
have an independent commission because
the problem is the party that has the
advantage doesn't want to have a TV
debate the only time you actually get a
debate is for instance the Prime
Minister thinks they're behind and a
leader opposition
to get publicity and that's exactly what
happened with Gordon Brown and Gordon
Brown called it right of my suggests
because he was behind to have the debate
and I think the debate between Gordon
Brown and David Cameron and Nick Clegg
was very good I when we go out on
campaigning during the general elections
we have a campaign session in the
morning and in the evening at sorry in
the afternoon and in the evening it's
between 5:00 and 7:00 p.m. and I
remember getting back after campaigning
and going to the gym putting a headsets
on and listening to the debates and that
the only thing I actually really
remember about it was the phrase I agree
with Nick but it was a very useful thing
for for electors to help make up their
mind how to vote yes of course I mean
isn't that part of the problem the both
of them for Street and it should
actually be someone with a credible
possibility of being Prime Minister and
what we ended up with was Clegg mania
and the disastrous coalition government
and when I talk about my private
member's bill a little later on I've
explained that I'm only going to have
the leader the Prime Minister and leader
of opposition debating me because I
think if it's the leaders debate we're
looking at who's going to be Prime
Minister
but there are some spin-off advantages
to us here in this chamber if we have
leaders debates there's nothing worse as
a candidate to be told that you're
getting the leader of your party to
visit your constituency you know you'll
lose days of campaigning because of it
first of all they ask you to find a
suitable venue something that ties into
everything that they want to promote you
desperately find somewhere talk to the
people that they agree to it and the
party officials say no we don't want
that
for something else and then eventually
they decide on somewhere else they send
down these advanced team of young people
who boss you around and tell you how to
run things in your constituency that's
another day lost and then eventually the
leader turns out you have a PR event
calendar camera and directors it call at
the time where all these people are
asking difficult questions to the Prime
Minister know they work or leader
opposition they're all planted there's
no real debate there at all so you lose
three or four days so if we had these
leaders debate that's at least a few
days when they can't come and visit us
in our constituency where I disagree
slightly with some of the things that
have been said before is the idea that
these leaders debates dominate the
decision-making of the British public
and I don't think that's the case and I
don't actually think there's a national
swing anymore
I think voters are much more savvy now
and vote on what are their interests and
when you look at the last general
election there are all sorts of strange
results that if they've been done
it will make that sort of difference but
I think isn't the important part of the
democratic process and the arguments I
hear against it you know it's all about
performance and not substance isn't that
what I used to say people used to say
before they televised the houses of
parliament it was exactly the same
arguments and we now see that they were
completely wrong what I really wanted to
talk to you
miss charmer about today is my private
member's bill it's it is for the
televised leaders debate Commission and
it was given its first reading I think
in 2017 it should be ought to be debated
on the 15th of March it's the second
bill on that day the first bill being
prime minister accountability to the
House of Commons which is actually my
name also but I can assure the house
that if on that day that bill won't be
moved the first bill will be the leaders
debate so we have an opportunity in
March to actually move this whole press
process forward I know that government
has a little legislative time because of
brexit but this is a private member's
bill and if on the 15th of March nobody
objects we can move forward and actually
get this bill as an act of Parliament
and I hope that both the opposition and
the government will allow the house to
make its own decision on this and not
try and block it by some parliamentary
procedure and much of what skynews are
saying now is what my bill already
proposes to do it is to set up a
commission an independent commission
with the responsibility to have a number
of leaders debates during the regulated
period
now my bill calls for three debates one
with the leaders of all the parties
represented in the House of Commons at
the time of the general election the
second and third would be between the
prime minister and leader of the
Opposition for what my honourable friend
mentioned we want to look at who is
likely to be the prime minister but
equally I did not want to leave out the
smaller parties now there is a problem
and I accept this point by having the
leaders of the parties in the House of
Commons you don't have every part you
know but would you really want a
communist VMP party in the debate I
think not there was a serious problem of
course we've you kicked by the height of
its power it didn't have any MPs but it
had clearly clearly a very large support
so I'll leave that down to the
Commission to decide whether they
brought any other leader of a party in
it but anyone who was any part of
represented in the house would have
their leader would have to attend and by
the way this will be optional we
couldn't have the Prime Minister
offloading it to somebody else or leader
Roberts you know they would have to
attend now people say that will take up
lots and lots of times at the party
leaders I have to say if they have to
prep for weeks on end they're not much
good as a leader they should know what
they think they should be out to go out
there and debate and these are good
under my bill they're going to be proper
debates the moderator will ask some
question but the Prime Minister and
leader opposition will be out to debate
with each other come back and forth so
there is an actual debate not a reason
we don't have rehearse lines being
delivered and then moving on now a
proper debate and you know we can argue
that we don't have a presidential system
now but we've moved I'm afraid a very
long way towards a presidential system
and I have to say since since Tony Blair
and I remember last election
Conservative MPs were all there standing
with Theresa that was the message that
was on that went down well but but it
was what it it was seen because the
leader is so associated with the local
politics so I do think that really
worries me and perhaps one of the
concerns about formalizing a TV debate
schedule but I mean I've said in three
Parliament's no mr. mrs. mr. Sharma and
two of those have been hand Parliament's
and one with a very small minority so it
does not reflect the requirement for a
TV debate to actually make sure that
every single political party like a
potentially former part of the power of
the government has a full role in these
debates to head-to-head with the Prime
Minister and be in opposition
I'm one with all parties now I'm saying
that's the minimum and I do accept that
it's the Commission thought it was a
right to have more debates they could do
it but I just want to have the minimum
number that we must have and I would say
these are compulsory they're not not
optional they the leaders have to turn
up as to the makeup of the Commission
this is where it goes slightly away from
what Sky News have suggested my view one
of the one of the Commission members
should be nominated Prime Minister won
by the lead proposition two by
broadcasters and three by the Speaker of
the House of Commons on one of those
nominated by the speaker to be chairman
and the Commission to serve for the
whole of that Parliament and then a new
commission set up depending on how the
election results
work so it's slightly different but it
would be funded entirely by the
broadcaster's the object would be to
have as much coverage as possible and I
think it would help inform the debate
now magister address these remarks
directly to the minister I'm sure we I
know because we've got a very good
Minister that she'll take on board what
we're saying but this is one of the
opportunities for the government to do
something now that will benefit
democracy when the general election
comes around we know that the Prime
Minister is not going to lead the
Conservative Party Internet next general
election she said that so I think it's a
great opportunity as part of her leg
legislature city to to do this and I do
hope it won't be dismissed out of hand
one of the great advantages of the
debate today for me is that when the
second reading debate is held in March
even if we only have limited time I can
point to this debate to say this is what
members said here and one of the reasons
I haven't published the the bill yet is
because I wanted to hear what members
said today so that that could be
incorporated and in the bill and I'm
entirely take on the point that my
honourable friend from also nuclear said
about the two polling days about the
postal vote today and the the actual
polling day and it seems to me
absolutely right
that the leaders debate was with all
party leaders should be before postal
vote date and at Lee and at least one of
the head-to-head should be before postal
voting day and I will now incorporate
that in my draft bill and I hope members
here can find time to serve on the bill
committee
forward so that all the details men that
worked out and then I mean I hope it's
this Minister will be on the bill
committee and then when we get there we
can get an act of parliament now some
people say I've been hopeful I managed
already to get one of my private
member's bills as an act of Parliament
in this way in this in this Parliament
I've also got another one as it happens
on drone regulation which seems to have
some relevance so from private member's
bills we can get what out what the
electorate want just honourable
gentleman for allowing me to intervene
and I'd agree with him that this is
entirely sensible and inevitable but
surely the fear is that this petition
and this campaign may well be kicked
into the long grass by the government
and I bring up the point about the
electoral laws which I think are widely
accepted as being outdated in the sense
that in February 2016 the Law Commission
actually published this interim report
calling for its current laws governing
elections to be rationalized into a
single consistent legislative framework
governing all elections now the
government is yet to respond three years
later so what chance has the Honourable
Jenkins bill gotten in terms of seeing
the light of day in due course but on
this particular one the public want it
the broadcasters want it I'm gonna argue
most MPs want it and I would argue this
is an opportunity so the government to
do the right thing and we actually need
a bit of goodwill at the moment so it
would be quite a nice thing to do and
I've gone on for long enough I just want
to thank members for coming those who
come to support it and those are coming
to oppose it wait would would would they
all remember join me in paying tribute
to the extraordinary and supremely able
editor of Sky News my friend from ITN
John Riley for being the driving force
behind this
you know what I was somebody I was
supposed to study that earlier on I
think oh I did
I did mention Sky News but it is john
riley and he has done really well and
i'm also to show that i'm also to thank
Adam Bolton for what he's been doing as
died news who's always fair and balance
when it comes to bricks it thank you so
much for this interview mr. Sharma and
I'm really interested in what other
members say so that I can hopefully
incorporate some of those comments into
the building grand stranger I turned up
here today to listen to the debates and
possibly to make an intervention and I
suppose I start following the excellent
speech from the Honourable member for
Wellingborough with with two
disappointments one is the
disappointments that there are more
honorable and right honorable members
president this is an important issue
which I can guarantee that every member
of parliament has a view on how debates
on television and the media should be
conducted during the period of a a
general election it's a disappointment
they're not more of turned up is it's
disrespectful to the hundred and thirty
thousand people who've petitioned for
this debate in US and any doesn't do
justice to what is a a very important
debate in indeed my second
disappointment is that I think the three
honorable members who've spoken before
me of all come to the conclusion that we
need a quango to regulate debates and I
reluctantly agree with them in the way
that our Constitution
folks eaters it has had the merits
because we don't have a written
constitution of being flexible so when
the world changes the process a
processes within this place and
electorally change and if people were
acting with it in a democratic spirit
and with goodwill one would expect
there's television as develops as that
made years develops that there would
have been a response by the politicians
and the political parties to respond to
that and to enable people to benefit
from having the debate broadcast in
their front rooms on on television that
hasn't happened for the reasons that the
Honourable member for Wellingborough is
stated very explicitly that leaders of
the Opposition when they're massively
ahead in the opinion polls don't want to
debate it why would they risk hitting a
banana skin and certainly Prime
Minister's when they're in number 10 and
they're ahead in the opinion polls want
to avoid exactly the same banana skin so
I think we do have to have a regulatory
body my heart sank when the Honourable
member for st. Austell anuki went
through the list of the Great and the
good who would have to serve on a quango
that would regulate television debates
judges so not early sadly mr. Sharma we
have developed a a population of quango
crowds who serve on many quangos and
scratch each other's back I know from
one quango to another and met that means
that sometimes we don't get the breadth
and the quality
within those organizations that we
should and I will make a a party's on
point here from the particular position
I've taken on the Briggs Lee debate it
is extraordinary that the Electoral
Commission is its total membership I'll
remain us and it is a really difficult
problem that we have in setting up any
quango that we don't go to this pool of
people who often public spirit Lee I
don't want to be too mean I've made
themselves available to to serve on
quangos and he's a very close group so
yes reluctantly we have to have a body
that will look at the the complicated
issues that are involved but I do hope
it's not the list that was given by the
the able motivator of this motion it's
important that we have this do these
televised debates discussions in
whatever forms that said because we
sometimes don't state the blindingly
obvious that the debate is actually at
the core of democracy and at the core of
our society and we need to have that in
as many forums as we can when BBC was
the monopoly broadcaster in the 1950s it
might have been sensible just to have it
on on the BBC but we have a range of
social media different television
broadcasts we can access television
stations from around the world as well
as the traditional print media we need
to make sure that where there is
regulation on television where most
people look to during a general election
for the discussion the viewing figures
for the debates in 2010 were immense and
I don't think however much Clegg mania
we had in
in that election I I got worried because
if I look to the figures the Lib Dems
were going to get a huge number of folks
in my constituency I went out every day
and I suppose I must have knocked on a
Lib Dem door but nobody admitted to it
through the whole of the hold of that
campaign so it didn't those debates were
important people challenged each other
leaders challenged to each other I don't
think they changed very much during our
debate this is being the case in in many
elections I remember the opinion polls
sticking over on the bottom of the sky
television screen in the 1997 election
and the opinion constantly shifted half
a point during the whole of that
election but we we live in a time where
the world is changing and politics are
more fluid than they've ever been and we
need a a response to that particular
issue
and that is why it would be the very
difficult job of a a regulatory body
it's a balance of the major parties what
who was invited because it is said
rather glibly that only the leaders of
the parties that are likely to be Prime
Minister should be there if mr. Shong
one looks at the Canada experience the
people who were going to be Prime
Minister in Canada before an election I
think was probably about eight or nine
years ago weren't one of the major
parties got 2% you'd look at the major
changes that have happened within
countries within the European Union
parties that were permanently in the
ascendancy like Social Democrats in
Sweden are now minor parties and
sometimes he's changing something very
quickly and there has never been a more
intense scientific base so it's going to
be a very do
pickles job for any regulatory body that
is settled but I do think it is vital
because it isn't just that there are a
lot of different outlets for information
nowadays we have coined the phrase fake
news for a lot of the information that
has been about in elections and
referenda because of the Internet
one of the great things about a debate
is the ability to challenge and to false
or to challenge lies basically and and
in the old creature you know if you keep
on telling lies I'll keep on telling the
truth did that that is the purpose of
debate and when people have complained
about the referendum that certain facts
were in facts or were facts but he's the
purpose of debate to expose that and
what better place than on television
with a huge audience to get that out
while the 2010 election I don't think
was affected by the television debates I
believe the 2017 debate was mercifully
affected by the debates quite simply
because of then Prime Minister did not
have the courage to go and debate she
would not put the case for the
Conservative Party and they went from
having a very large lead in the opinion
polls to not being able to form a
majority government so if anybody doubts
the power of the debates and I think the
television companies were right to empty
seat the Prime Minister and go ahead
without her it was a bit strange it
looked a bit strange but he did expose
the facts that the leader of one of our
major parties was unprepared to go up
and defend our party's position the
other example I can give of
on positive side of television debate
discussion not a formal leaders debate
but it certainly affected me seeing how
important he was honorable members will
remember the rise of the British
National Party not to any significant
extent but it looks as though they were
making progress when they were led by
the bottom-feeder Nick Griffin and when
he went on to question time all right
that evening I was in somebody's front
room I'm talking about talking about
pavements and street lighting and at the
end of the meeting they said to me are
you going to go and buy a bottle of wire
but what do these people know about my
drinking habits this is a bit strange
but every single one of those people
living in terraced houses in North
Manchester was going back to watch Nick
Griffin and Jack Straw and the other
party people on question time and
Griffin was destroyed and the BNP fell
apart and that really is the power of
debates and we should do as much however
complicated it is dealing with parties
who have significant support with no
representation and those parties like
the SNP and bio Murray whose primary
objectives is to get out of this place
and do not want to be Prime Minister but
clearly have a significant Democratic
impact in the whole of the United
Kingdom how those particular positions
can be facilitated so I think on those
points one could go on it's an important
issue we should support and from what
the Honourable member from
Wellingborough said I wish him well with
his bill it may need some tweaks but I
think the whole of the House of Commons
and House of Lords should get together
because when we're away from elections
we all believe in that it is only the
vested interest that we think we can
grub an election with
debating it that stops people doing it
so I didn't intend to speak mr. Sharma
but it's a good debate it's a shame more
people aren't here and sky o to be
congratulated as other people who sign
the petition for stimulating this
discussion today and also commend the
organizers of this petition and the
petitions committee for allowing time
for this delete behead and honorable
member will friend force and also and
Yuki for moving the debate moving the
motion and so effectively I agree with
the words of the former deputy prime
minister Lord Whitelaw who said in the
House of Lords in 1990 that Sky News had
and I caught a very high reputation I
admired it as do many other people and
those comments from 1990 are certainly
relevant today the broadcaster is
award-winning
picking up BAFTAs and Royal Television
News Channel of the Year awards
therefore has a strong reputation for
news coverage and that comes from its
strength and the quality of this
journalists whether it be better it be
and coin way mark stone mark white this
broadcaster and doubt
and that's why mr. Sharma I cannot
understand where this channel has
threatened to this amiable reputation by
devoting so much coverage and airtime to
his own campaign and petition for this
leaders debates commission and I'm going
to shatter the consensus which is thus
far and convene or this debate in this
day and age when we're all concerned by
fake news and the reliability of what we
read watch and interact with I do
question the editorial decision by Sky
News to constantly report on his own
campaign as if it we're actual news when
it's simply an attempt to gather more
signatures for his own campaign now this
campaign a petition on the parliaments
website started in early September 2000
then 18 ahead of the party conscious
season since then Sky News has been
reporting on its progress
almost every half-hour and certainly
every other latterly there has been a
running total of the number of
signatures in the top left-hand corner
of the Sky News screen together with its
campaign hashtag during political
moments of the brakes of debate from
this place moments of crisis for the
government's or elsewhere in the world
when while wildfires were sweeping
California on Korra for conflicts was
raging in Yemen Sky News still found
time to insert and promote its campaign
for election debates now if the petition
was gathering huge support then maybe it
might be out of course it should be
reported by Sky News but that argument
falls flat when one looks at the other
petitions appearing on the parliaments
petitioned website there's a petition
calling for the ban on the sale of
fireworks
currently with 297 thousand signatures
twice the level of support the Sky News
petition has there's a petition asking
for the UK to leave the EU without a
deal again almost 300,000 people had
supported a petition and there's another
calling for the lowering of the age for
smear test from 25 to 18 to prevent
cancer set up by a young cancer sufferer
with 93 thousand signature
now my point mr. Sharma is that but for
the fact that Sky News was the promoter
of this campaign it would not have been
gathering the airtime and the signatures
that it has I've struggled to find any
coverage of any of these other petitions
which have either attracted more support
or are arguably more worthy on any other
sky news outlets now 165 of my 74,000
constituents sign this petition and
despite the best efforts of Sky News
only one one has asked me to attend
today's debate I felt so strongly about
this and so strongly about the misuse of
Sky News preferred position and
broadcast media promoting his own
campaign and petition I felt I had to
come and speak now I want to say a few
words about my own views on the leaders
debate and the idea about setting up a
commission now general elections in the
United Kingdom are not about electing a
president waters elect 650 individual
MPs from which a government is there in
formed now my experience from previous
elections both for this place and to the
Scottish Parliament when leaders debates
have taken place is that this suck the
oxygen away from local campaigns and
rather than focusing on the merits of
each candidate's and local issues they
focus on the doorsteps about what will
happen in the debates of what has just
happened in the leaders debates the
media reporting becomes all about how
well or not each of the different
leaders performed who looked good who
answered the best questions had to do
broadcasters appear how did the
newsreaders appear not about the
substantive issues of the election
campaign so for a period of time
journalists are not reporting on the
critical issues of the election but
become more like commentators as a
boxing match now in 2010 as mentioned by
a number of honourable members already
it was perceived that Nick Clegg had
performed well in the debate which
resulted in errors of coverage of the
so-called liberal Democrat bounce but
the actual results should end in touch
with little or no change in a liberal
Democrat support so how much influence
do these debates actually have in my
view this drive for leaders debates is
simply that the media machine and
journalists trying to insert themselves
onto election campaign rather than doing
their job of reporting on the key
election issues of the day
they provide little new information to
voters lastly we have the added
complication in the United Kingdom that
there are four nations within our
kingdom two kingdom with differing
political perspectives from each of them
now if a leaders debate is about
assessing high potential player
ministers perform how does this methods
of model accommodates
smaller parties such as the Scottish
National Party the DUP applied a number
of other members already commented on
this these parties may have significant
supports in their own part of the
country but there's no prospect of their
leader occupying dynasties and this
proposal by by Sky News does not
accommodate what is essentially a way of
scrutinizing presidential candidates I
note the Honourable my wonderful friend
for Wellingborough did and his proposal
suggest an alternative but that I don't
think actually flex the huge regional
variations and between the in between
different parts of United Kingdom in
terms of how we vote why for example
should voters in Cornwall have to listen
to the leader of the Scottish National
Party well none of the waters in
Cornwell have any prospect if it did
they have a desire and ought to vote for
the leader of the Scottish National
Party now in the lesson which we all
received from John rile the head of Sky
News ahead of this debate we were told
that an independent commission would
remove the ability of political leaders
to block debates because of narrow
political interest now my question is if
it is politicians who are blocking this
from moving forward
where are the BBC and ITV and all of us
they've been pretty quiet ahead of to be
today's debate I think that's pretty
telling either private discussions with
the BBC and ITV I think the number of
members and this place will have done
likewise and their views I will suggest
yes
that I was interviewed by BBC Scotland
and Scotland today this gotten this
morning about this debate and there was
a great deal of interest from the BBC
and Scotland in it so I'm grateful for
for my appointment and from my positions
perspective doesn't there has not been
much interest my point was more about
the management within the itv management
than BBC BBC scotland they are not as
supportive as Sky News editorial team
behind Sky News appear to have been in
terms of pushing this campaign it is
they have not got equivalent petitions
running and sound they are not added
their support to the petition being run
by Sky News now look forward to hearing
the rest of today's debate and the
ministers responds I could have said
more of I had thought that more of
members apply more colleagues would have
wanted to have contribute you into this
debate given it as headline news but it
is headline news course can use it would
seem but very few other people thank you
mr. Sharma Thank You mr. Sharma it's a
pleasure to serve under your
chairmanship I joined with other
honourable members across the chamber in
congratulating my honourable friend and
fellow Southwest MP the member first
endosterol a new key for the way he has
introduced this debate and to the
petitions committee as well for bringing
it forward I also join other colleagues
in congratulating Sky News for
initiating this and they are to be
congratulated certainly for achieving
130,000 signatures on this petition as
my honorable friends who've just spoke
said not for want of trying
due to the the fairly widespread
coverage that Sky News were able to give
I suppose I should start mr. Sharma my
remarks with a sort of informal
declaration of interest and that is to
say that before I reached this place I
was a broadcast journalist for 20 years
working for much of the time not for Sky
News at all
but for the BBC starting to sound less
like a declaration of interest and more
like an admission of guilt isn't it
but but I'm nonetheless because of that
background I do take close interest as
people will be unsurprised I suspect in
the interaction between the broadcast
media and democracy I have seen it from
both sides poacher turned gamekeeper if
you like and although I cannot claim
ever to have been in the exalted heights
of editorial management at the BBC in
which I was responsible for anything so
important as a televised national
election debate I was nonetheless
involved on a regional level
at organising debates as between
candidates in individual constituencies
I think many of the arguments actually
run across the piece and I will admit to
being slightly torn when I heard about
this petition because fundamentally as a
now a democratically elected politician
and before that a broadcaster I
absolutely want us to do everything
possible to engage more people in the
democratic process I think that's
absolutely vital where my problem lies
is I remain to be convinced that
televised election leaders debate all
the way to achieve that and I'll go on
to just say a few reasons why I believe
that to be the case I was also torn as
to the precise merits of this petition
as it is written until that is I looked
at it in detail now the the coverage
that Sky News have been giving it as my
honourable friend made clear has I think
made one think that it's about simply
who should be organizing a debate an
Independent Electoral Commission in
other words but one actually looks at
the wording of the petition it seeks to
go far further than that and this is
where I have the problem because I quote
the petition wording says amend election
law to
make party leaders take part in a
televised debate and that I'm afraid is
where it lost me and it lost me for a
number of reasons the first one is it's
not a matter for legislation to make
party leaders take part in an election
debate the second problem that I have
with this is and I don't wish to be
facetious about this but suppose in a
parallel universe a parliament was to
pass this law and make it mandatory for
party leaders to take part in an
election debate how are they to be
forced so to do as I say I don't wish to
be facetious but if a party leader the
prime minister or the leader of the
Opposition declines to take part in such
a debate what is to happen on the night
of the debate is is an independent
commission to send beefeaters with
spears to force them into a carriage and
take them to television centre to take
part it just doesn't seem to me that it
is plausible to suggest that such
legislation could possibly work of
course I give way to monitoring if it is
the law of the land at the leader of the
Opposition and the Prime Minister attend
these debates they will do so to do
otherwise these things would be
outrageous but I don't see that it's
enforceable I take the Honorable
gentleman's point that it would be
probably outrageous as far as their
electoral ambition was concerned not to
take part and as the point was made very
eloquently earlier on I think there is
some sign that not taking part in a
debate probably doesn't do a leader any
good I still stick to the point that I
am not clear how one would force a party
leader to take part in such an event so
I'm not convinced that the petition is
calling for something that in reality
can be delivered now generally speaking
although I said very clearly that I
many moves to make the democratic
process more accessible to residents to
our constituents I'm not convinced TV
debates are the way to do that as other
members have said so I won't develop
this point at length unnecessarily they
haven't historically been part of our
democratic process only in 2010 did the
first election leaders debates occur we
spoke earlier on about the figures so
using the wonders of new technology I've
got that the the figures for the 2010
debates here their substantial viewing
figures it's true for the first debate
ITV hosted that and ninety point nine
million viewers watched the second
debate hosted by Sky News four point two
million viewers and the third debate on
my former employer the BBC eight point
six million not insubstantial but not
massive just for comparison sake Call
the Midwife on Christmas Day which was
my eight point seven million people
about two weeks ago the broadcast has
slightly shot themselves in the foot
after 2010 I have to say by trying to
make the point that if you added up
those three figures a total of
twenty-two point seven million people
watch these debates
mr. Sharma that's a bit like saying
because I'm speaking in this debate now
in this chamber and I also hope to speak
in a debate later in the main chamber
that somehow miraculously there's two of
me but that's not what those viewing
figures show at all as indeed the
organisation full fact okay whose
website I just accessed make the point
as well so I think it is debatable how
much the debates really are popular and
really are relied upon by members of the
public in order to make their decision
we don't have a presidential system as
has been described and whether people
might think well we've moved towards
that whether we like it or not
constitutionally the voting public do
not vote for a Prime Minister yes of
course
the national elections are certainly for
the parties who fight seats across the
United Kingdom is on the basis of
manifestos would the Honorable gentlemen
like to compare the number of people who
read our manifestos with the number of
people who watched the television
debates because he's absolutely right
this is not a presidential debate but
the leaders are putting forward their
manifestos well manifestos are not in my
experience ever going to make it to the
top of the bestsellers lists that's very
true
however what I'm going to come on to
saying he makes a perfectly reasonable
point is that I think there are other
ways in which parties and party leaders
can get their message across and sell
their manifestos if you like other than
the idea of a TV leaders debate but my
main concern that I have about the idea
of party leaders debates and this was a
bleep mentioned by a my little friend
earlier is that they have a tendency to
suck the oxygen out of the rest of the
campaign now I take a rather
old-fashioned view about this and
perhaps I am aiming for some sunlit
uplands that have long since dissipated
even if they ever existed in the first
place but I would quite like election
campaigns to be about ideas and policies
and ideologies I don't want them to be
about whether the Prime Minister was
wearing kitten heels and whether the
leader of the Opposition was on the
podium on the right or the left and what
color tie the leader of a third party
might have been wearing and whether the
TV host hosting that particular event
did a good job or not but that is what
you get if you have a campaign which is
let's say bookended by two election
debates perhaps a fortnight apart you
get the first week before debate number
one looking forward to debate number one
the second week looking back at debate
number one the third week look
forward to debate number two and the
fourth week looking back at debate
number two when do you ever have time in
that to actually have a debate about
policies and about ideas and the
difficulty is that is what you will end
up with and I speak mr. Sharma with a
little experience having worked not only
in politics in this country but in
Australia as well and having worked on
election campaigns over there where
there is a longer history of leaders
debates on television they're not hugely
watched I have to say but they happen
and the public expect them to happen but
the entire election campaign tends to be
about the debate and the process of the
debate rather than the ideas that might
be discussed during it and my concern is
that that is what we end up with if you
rely on a debate as being the means to
get people interested in the democratic
process let me move on briefly if I may
to what I imagine to start with was the
substance of the petition which was to
set up an independent debates Commission
and this is an idea with which I have a
great deal of sympathy if if there is to
be leaders election debate we absolutely
have to end the current frankly chaotic
system where the rival broadcasters
jockey for position they put forward
opposing ideas of formats they argue
about how high the podium is going to be
and whether they'll enter stage left or
stage right and that's before you start
getting the individual parties having
their say and one side thinks that a
particular format put forward by one
broadcaster would favor their man or
woman the other party says no we prefer
the other one what do you end up with
you either end up with no debate or you
end up with frankly a month's worth of
ridiculous discussion about something
that really only a few nerds in politics
and broadcasting are interested in and
once again you get absolutely no further
forward in discussing the ideas or the
policies I'm not convinced that an
independence debate commission would
change any of that the other thing that
I'm not convinced
that is even if they were set up with a
great deal of legislative power behind
them they are not going to be immune
from the sort of pressure which is
brought to bear currently on the
broadcasters by the different party
leaders who are jockeying for a
different format one from the other I'm
not convinced either they would be
immune from potential legal action and
the point was well made by a colleague
earlier on define a party leader someone
could suddenly set themselves up as a
party leader so where does that leave
you do you then say it's only potential
prime ministers who may be allowed to
take part it's so very difficult circle
to square I am not convinced that an
independent debates commission would
have any success in doing that
my overall view however is that I think
we're barking up the wrong tree here I
absolutely want more people to be
involved in the democratic process it's
vital and I could understand if we were
having this discussion maybe twenty or
thirty years ago but I think the boat
has sailed on TV election debates on
expecting people to sit down at nine
o'clock on a random Tuesday evening to
watch something on linear television
even though it'll be repeated and
watched on the iPlayer or the Sky
version thereof the fact is I think TV
debates feel to me like they're a bit
old hat in 2019 there are many more ways
in which we can be encouraging and
should be encouraging people to access
the democratic process and they are
doing so there are any number of social
media platforms in which in my
experience in the last general election
is where the real policy debates seemed
to be happening I am Not sure that
mandating now in 2019 for a TV election
debate in primetime he's really looking
forward at all I think it's probably
looking backwards and I would add I was
much taken with the point made I think
was the Honourable member for Stroud who
made the point about the need for our
regional broad car
to get involved more in the democratic
process and I think that's absolutely
criminalized I speak of someone who
spent most of his career in regional
broadcasting in my area BBC spotlight
and ITV West country do do a very good
job with the coverage of their local
politics but maybe we ought to be
thinking about those outlets taking a
greater role in ensuring that some of
the issues are debated and are done so
on a level which is more relevant to
people in their constituencies so mr.
Sharma I won't seek to detain colleagues
any longer but in conclusion I
understand the principle behind the
petition I do applaud Sky News for
initiating it I'm not opposed to leaders
debates per se I just remain unconvinced
that they are the way forward and I am
utterly unconvinced that it is possible
or desirable to make it mandatory that
they must happen if they are to take
place in the future because of some
agreement that they should then yes I
absolutely see the argument in favor of
a debates commissioned to independently
that's the key word independently decide
on their format and their timing
therefore taking out of the hands of the
broadcasters and of party leaders but
overall seeking to make delays in
mandatory is I believe not the way
forward I remain very uncomfortable with
that and I applaud the decision of the
government which I assume the Minister
is about to repeat from an earlier
response to the petition which is that
the government should not be changing
the law in this direction I mean
drama and it is a pleasure to serve
under your direction it's Ally and I
normally on a Monday morning spend time
traveling down from Scotland to to take
part in the the afternoons business
today was a little different though
already here I had the great privilege
and honor of being interviewed live by
live on Sky News on their platform that
they have on college screen and very
interesting experience today as well
because it was a cornucopia of the
dissenters heckling and providing a
narrative to the entire episode
including some members of the English
Defence League and an evangelical
gentleman who was encouraged me to
repent my sins all the way through the
interview but in the middle of that
experience the redoubtable Adam Balkin
asked me whether or not I would have
you
hey here particularly not a new quango
were to be set up but my response would
be that well I would have more faith in
an independent commission to organize TV
debates than I do in the way that it is
done at present which is a chaotic and
anarchic amalgam of political fixers
getting together to try and do what is
best for them and the broadcaster's
trying to do what is best for them so
the idea of putting this onto a
statutory footing and having written
down the responsibilities and the rights
that the Commission must adhere to in
organizing base that is very attractive
to me indeed and I think there are three
immediate benefits that would arise from
this the first is that it would take the
matter out of party politics out of the
hands of the political fixtures and
actually provide a level playing field
and a set of fair rules that everyone
would have to abide by and whilst they
may and sure prove inconvenient from
time to time or troublesome from time to
time to some or other of the parties
they would nonetheless be it be a
situation where everyone had to play by
the same set of rules the other reason
why I would welcome an independent
commission is that it would give us the
opportunity to ensure that not just
third party but fourth fifth sixth and
other minority voices are represented in
the debate and the other reason why I
think an independent commission would be
useful as well it's because it would
allow some discussion to take place and
some control over the format of the
debates to take place and we haven't
spent much time this afternoon talking
about format but I would understand why
a lot of people might be skeptical about
the idea of television debates if they
resemble to the the circus we have every
Wednesday afternoon at Prime Minister's
Questions for example which is a you
know an exercise in how the executive is
not accountable to the legislature with
pre-arranged and quite often you know
pre rehearse questions and answers being
traded for the benefit of the other TV
cameras but not really an exercise and
screw
the northern exercise in debate so
allowing a more inquisitive format where
people are allowed to truly challenge
each other and and are subject to
perhaps third party questioning in
moderation as well that seems to me
something that would be extremely
beneficial now until the last two
colleagues spoke I was worried that this
was a bit of a one-sided debate actually
and we were we were having this
consensus among among all of those it
spoke previously but there have in the
in the last 20 minutes or so being some
arguments against the principle of
having the television debates at all
never mind whether they're run by an
independent commission or not and I
think it's important as we consider how
this argument develops we look at those
arguments against and see whether or not
they have validity and whether they and
themselves could be countered and I want
to just spend a couple of minutes with
some of them the the first is the
suggestion which has has been hinted at
which this is somehow a matter of
trivialized serious political discourse
that it's actually taking politics and
important decisions and and putting them
on television in the name of perhaps or
of entertainment well it seems to me
actually that by having an independent
commission that is the best way to guard
against the trivialization of politics
and it being presented as entertainment
because we can actually build into the
process quite clear rules that prevent
that from happening and I also think
that when you know party organizers or
media or a broadcast officers whoever's
responsible for this expressed concerns
of this nature I think they're being a
little disingenuous because these are
the very same people who spend an awful
lot of time and an awful lot of money
trying to look at the very latest social
media platforms and make sure that they
are you know as using them as
effectively as possible often by
trivializing or certainly condensing the
political message so that it is easily
understood on those very limited
platforms which they they make use of
and the the other suggestion that's been
put about the other argument against it
is it well how would you define
what a leader is and I want to just
discuss here the role of the SNP in
particular in such debates because the
the Honorable gentleman from from
barrack Shaw Roxburgh and cellco
suggested that someone watching in
Cornwall might not care very much about
what the leader of the Scottish National
Party would have to say where she to
take part in a debate and and perhaps
perhaps that would be because he's
assuming that the leader of the Scottish
National Party would talk about matters
only in relation to Scotland which is of
course the principal brief of the of the
SNP but it seems to me that these
debates also provide an opportunity for
everyone in the place for the elections
taking place which for now would be the
United Kingdom for everyone to ask the
question well what type of government do
we wish to get out of this electoral
process and as the Honorable gentleman
knows his side was successful of mine
unsuccessful back in 2014 and the
Scottish independence referendum and
therefore for now Scotland remains part
of the United Kingdom which means its
representatives in this Parliament have
every bit as much light as anyone else
to determine and to influence the
character of the government of the
United Kingdom so I think that people in
cornwall and everywhere else in the
united kingdom would be extremely
interested to know what the criteria
would be that the SNP would adopt in
this parliament where it's successful in
the election in terms of determining who
should form the next government of the
united kingdom let's see if you do the
same point well you took you faster i'm
very very grateful and just to clarify
the point I was making it's not that the
people of Cornwall would not care about
what the leader of their same people
want to see but if she's not in your
party if not on the ballot paper on
Cornwall suit of Cornwall will not have
the opportunity to vote SNP even if they
wanted to if you extend their arguments
or the argument you're putting forward
which other parties
do you include in the debate if they're
also not on the ballot paper well look
can I just take the points issue it's I
presume relevant to the same point it is
the vulnerable German I thank the
Honorable 10
giving away the along cinema makes the
point about actually having the right
people into the right to vote and you're
quite right where the SNP has MPs and
Westminster quite where they should be
taking part in the Westminster bear
debate so shouldn't it be Westminster
leaders that take part in Westminster
debate and then MSP leadership taken by
an MSP debate so you wouldn't want to
either may in a debate fry devolve
Parliament so therefore it shouldn't be
Nicola Sturgeon having debate for a
Westminster
it should be your Westminster leader you
see people suggested early on this
debate that of course the British system
is not a presidential system so it's not
just a matter of who becomes the prime
minister or indeed we don't elect prime
ministers at the election which is
constitutionally absolutely correct so
for me the purpose and TV bits isn't
just to say well who's going to be the
next prime minister and have some
gladiatorial contests against the the
potential challengers for that position
it's a matter of saying well what do we
want the government of the country to be
what are the serious issues it should
adopt what are its priorities what is
its general direction and that is where
TV debates can prove extremely useful in
trying to educate the public and raise
awareness of these very important issues
so and having an independent commission
of course gives us or them the
opportunity to make sure that matters
are conducted in a way which allows that
to happen rather than it being seen as
some sort of presidential contest
there's also been a suggestion that that
somehow it's a bit it's somehow not
quite right that Parliament should be
seeking to make regulations on
broadcasters on this matter that
actually it's up to them to cover
politics in whatever way they see fit in
the the Honorable gentlemen of course
was critical of Sky in particular in
their their their editorial judgments
that they make to cover their own
campaign well I would say this that of
course there is much recognition about
the conduct and coverage of elections
already in this country we have a very
highly regulated electoral system and
quite right too so that people are able
to challenge if something is seen to go
wrong so the idea of Parliament right
seeking to regulate the broadcast
coverage of an election campaign or any
other political campaign seems to be
entirely consistent with the fair and
democratic process that we have of
trying to make sure that all of these
matters are fairly regulated there was
also suggestion took forward that
somehow a national TV debate would
undermine
local campaigning I'm sorry I just don't
buy that in my experience as other
colleagues of nations people actually do
tune into the TDD debates because
perhaps of the way it's presented as a
television program but the effect of
doing that is to engage them with the
political process more generally and
they then move on having been duped is
the wrong word but having their in their
appetite whetted a little bit they move
on to take more interest in the local
campaigns and to ask questions perhaps
getting involved props turning up to
hustings there might be there for the
local candidates as well and these two
things can actually be a perfectly
symbiotic to each other one can
encourage the other and frankly anything
that we can do to try and stimulate
political awareness political engagement
is going to be for the long-term benefit
of our democracy can I return to this
question of the the role of minority
voices in this because I do think it's
very very important that we stress and I
say this to the Honorable gentleman from
Welling breast in these debates we need
to stress this is not any longer if it
ever was a two-party political system
there are third fourth fifth parties and
they have a right to be represented as
well so I my things were running out of
time is it ten minutes okay well I am
coming to an end but I want to stress
that okay i'm dangering over time but
I'll happily give
a powerful speech but the whole point of
my bill is to include a debate between
the leaders of the smaller parties as
well so it's not you know it's very
important what I would hope the SP would
support the bill because it does include
that provision okay but that is welcome
and I think that that is important but I
mean I've to make the point I would say
this that in the country that I
represents in in this chamber the two
major political parties laboratory
between them added together are lucky if
they can command half of the electorate
support so almost half of the entire
electorate places its allegiance with
parties other than the two main parties
in the United Kingdom and I think that
needs to be understood and that needs to
be built in to the process of doing this
in fact we had the situation before
Christmas for me the shenanigans about
the debate which of course wasn't meant
to be an election debate it would it
would have been a debate about Rex's
what to do with a situation where the
SNP the third party in this house in
terms of its representation the second
largest political party in the United
Kingdom in terms of its membership was
likely to be excluded from a debate that
was going to take place with didn't in
the end but it was going to take place
between the leaders of the conservative
and the Labour Party and this is all the
more bizarre when we and the the the
Shadow Minister might want to respond to
this but it's all the more bizarre given
that the leader of the Labour Party as I
understand it has said that if there
were to be a general election in the
coming months labour would be committed
in its manifesto to implementing brexit
may do it differently but it would
nonetheless be committed to implementing
breaks so therefore we were going to
have a debate between a conservative way
of doing brexit or a Labour way of doing
brexit ignoring other voices who didn't
want brexit that happened at all and it
conveniently ignoring the fact that now
consistently a majority of people in
opinion polls throughout the length and
breadth of the United Kingdom don't want
brexit at all
it is he's making outrageous claims
about how his knowledge of what the
British people but let's face it there
was one one referendum the decision was
made your side loss stop moaning about
it see I'm a Democrat and I believe that
in a democracy people of the right to
change their mind and it is quite clear
that a very large number of people who
voted for brexit three years ago have
now changed their mind when they
understand what it actually means but
leaving that to one side my point is
this that we were in danger of having a
debate before Christmas between the
leaders of the two main political
parties United Kingdom where the
alternative to brexit was not even going
to be represented in the debate so it
was just as well I feel that that didn't
go ahead mr. Davis let me just finish by
saying this that a number of people will
be concerned about the practicalities
and as to how these things can be can be
made to work and of course the
uniqueness of the British system and its
idiosyncrasies and how they can be
respected it should not be your be
beyond our ability and our wit to be
able to make this happen in Scotland
there are five parties represented in
the Scottish Parliament and there are
regularly five-way debates on broadcast
television and in other fora
which don't seem to present any great
difficulty at all there are many other
countries throughout the world who have
multi-party systems who have
proportionate electoral systems where of
course it's usual for governments to be
formed on the basis of coalition's
between a number of different parties
they have no difficulty in being able
for to have all of the party views
represented in broadcast televised
debates so if they can do it I suggest
that we should be able to do it as well
and let me just finish by saying to the
Minister I I know she keeps getting
being sent out to these types of debates
and and and has to say that the
government you know this wasn't in the
government manifesto I'm sure it wasn't
so therefore the government isn't minded
to do anything about it but I think I
think on this at least I would ask her
to accept that this should be an ongoing
and open debate and I would ask her to
consider playing a role in stimulating
that debate and in not closing her mind
or
her ears to the voices that are coming
that says we need to look at much better
regulation of something that has in fact
become part of our institutionalized way
of doing politics in this country anyway
we might as well accept that and try and
make it the best that it can be thank
you very much mr. Davis and it's been a
very interesting debate so far and I
think I'd like to say at the outset that
contrary to some of the colleagues who
spoke and I think that Sky News have
performed actually quite a valuable
public service in trying to take the
party politics out of the process of
election debates and allow us as
politicians to concentrate on how best
to present our policies which after all
is what really matters and so I think
that the government should stop digging
its heels in on this and back election
debates as an integral and important
part of our democracy there's no need to
wait let's just agree to debate now
we've had some very very good speeches
today including first of all from the
Honorable gentleman the member for st.
Austell and nuki who presented the
debate on behalf of the petitions
committee extremely Abele and he
referred to the recent chewing and
throwing about the possibility of a
brexit TV debate and other honourable
members have referred to that I'll come
back to that point I think later on in
my remarks but he also was intervened on
during the course of his remarks by the
honourable gentleman the member for
Akimov honest and de never who who
pointed out the necessity of involving
other parties in the debate process and
we've had further discussion about that
during the course of the baton I think
I'll come back to that in a moment
because it does raise some interesting
questions and the honourable gentleman
for Eddie Maurice speaking on behalf of
the SNP also raised this issues it does
raise interesting and complicated
questions when people participating in
the debate which is about electing this
House of Commons essentially are not
even candidates
in that election to the House of Commons
loan he made a very interesting argument
as to why that broader perspective
should be taken into account and I think
I won't give wait the Honorable lady
just because she hasn't been here for
the debate and I'm old-school with
regard to that I'm afraid but I'm happy
to give away otherwise but and it's not
personal it's just a that's the that's
the way I'd prefer to operate so um in
relation to what the Honorable gentle
was saying the the the member for
carmarthen East and to never he made a
very valid point but I think it does
raise interesting issues about which
party should be involved in these
debates and there certainly must be a
role and they must somehow be
incorporated whether it's through the
means suggested by the Honorable
gentleman for well umbrella or other
means they must be incorporated into
this process the Honorable gentleman for
st. Austell anuki also said that leaders
must much more visible and accessible
these days and then they used to be I'm
not sure that's entirely true Clement
Attlee when he was campaigning to be
Prime Minister in 1945 and in 1950
actually drove around the country with
his wife violet in a Hillman minx as
their way of engaging with the
electorate so it's certainly true that
times have changed but I add Leo so said
of course that being Prime Minister was
the job that took up the least amount of
his time of any job that he'd ever had
during his career it's interesting I
think what he said in regard to the
response to Parliament's own social
media questions about this debate and I
think some of the points being made
about the Americanization potential
Americanization of politics are very
important ones but of course the real
challenges I think are not about the
Americanization of politics through
having TV debates but about the
involvement of large sums of money being
involved in politics shadowy amounts of
money be involved in British politics
the activities of organizations like
Cambridge analytic and so on so I think
those are our issues that are perhaps
more compellingly worrying issues about
the Americanization of politics rather
than us having television debates the
Honourable gentleman my right my
honourable friend rather for stroud
quite rightly I think said that the
decision about
whether or not we should have debates if
we are going to have them or not
shouldn't just rest in the hands of the
Prime Minister and he quite rightly
pointed out the lack of regional
coverage in the television coverage of
politics these days he wanted to take
out of Party politics the issue of
debates and he referred to the Nixon
Kennedy debates I think there in the
course of his remarks and he said the
thing he knows about that is that Nixon
lost well interestingly of course
a lot of the polls showed that Nixon had
won particularly people had followed the
debates on the radio rather than on
television so it does make a very valid
point about the role of image in
people's political perspectives whether
or not the TV debate was responsible for
John Kennedy's narrow victory I think is
highly debatable not least because his
father Joseph Kennedy when asked why the
victory had been so narrow said that he
couldn't afford a landslide was his
response to it so again I think possibly
the use of money in American politics
are perhaps more compelling and more
important than the role of the debates
I'm tempted to say in response to the
Honorable gentleman the member for
Wellingborough who also mentioned the
2010 debates that took place that I
agree with Peter because much of much of
very unusually much of what he said I
did agree with and we look forward to
seeing the details of his private
member's bill I know he's a sort of
member who would never commit to
supporting a bill without having read
every clause and word of it and
carefully performing an exegesis of
every part of the bill and therefore I
want to make any commitments about his
bill until we've actually seen what it
says but it certainly did sound like it
contained some very interesting ideas
and we look forward to it surfacing on
the Ides of March as he suggested it was
going to do and hopefully it might have
a fate that is not support tension as
that date could otherwise suggest he
mentioned about the inclusion of the
minor parties in one of the debates
proposed in his bill and it is it is an
interesting area because of course it is
true that the part
he's with lower shares of the votes and
those that don't stand in all parts of
the United Kingdom that some of them
were represented in previous debates in
2015 for example when David Cameron
insisted on having a very diluted type
of debate because he didn't want to have
a head-to-head debate with Ed Miliband
he preferred to have a larger number of
voices and therefore possibly defuse the
impact of the overall event but
nevertheless interestingly at no point
in that despite the fact that it's the
conservative and unions party was it
suggested that the DUP should be one of
the parties participating in that debate
even though they are a party that only
stands in one of the Constituent
countries of the United Kingdom unlike
like Emery and unlike SMP they weren't
invited participate and neither were the
SDLP who at that time had members
elected to this house well the austere
unionists who have had members elected
to this house in recent times or indeed
although whether they turn upon or not
we don't know Shin Fame because although
they don't take their seats they stand
in the general election and have elected
MPs even though they don't come and take
the oath and take their seats in this
place so there is an asymmetry if you
like to the way that these debates have
been organized and that Northern Ireland
has largely been excluded from that
process even though it's an integral
part of the United Kingdom and it's
interesting now that we debate the issue
as I call it off the British border in
Ireland very very frequently because of
the backstop and because of brexit and
yet when it came to those general
election debates Northern Ireland was
treated as a sideshow and almost as a
separate election from the United
Kingdom general election in terms of
inviting people to participate in the
debate but we look forward to his bill
my honourable friend from blackly and
Broughton and spoke and reluctantly I
think accepted you'd have to have a coin
go in order to administer election
debates but I think quite rightly
pointed out that any such body should
have a much greater diversity than we
see in bodies like the Electoral
Commission and
to agree with him that there should be
different political views represented I
think it would also be important that
any such body should have
representations from the nations and
regions of the United Kingdom and indeed
from different social classes because
many of our bodies I think tend to be
made up of the same kind of people with
very very similar views and I thought
his suggestions for that were very
refreshing and interesting he also
discussed the 2010 debates and the
so-called Clegg mania which allegedly
resulted from the 2010 leadership
debates in fact of course interestingly
despite that spike in the polls the
Liberal Democrats won fewer seats in the
in the 2010 election than they'd held
before but because it was a hung
parliament ended up in government for
the next five years the Honourable
gentleman a member for baricza Roxburgh
and Selkirk
we're saying is it appropriate for a
broadcaster to campaign in this way I
think it would be wholly inappropriate
if they were campaigning on a political
policy issue mr. Davis but I don't think
it's inappropriate for a broadcaster and
I don't think it goes out with Ofcom
rules for a broadcaster to campaign in
this way for these debates I think it's
more difficult possibly for the BBC or
ITV as public service broadcasters to do
so they to our party to Ofcom rules but
they have there are special
considerations involved when there's a
public service broadcaster but I don't
agree with him that it was inappropriate
for Sky News to campaign on this and in
fact I will in a moment and in fact I
think in doing so they have provided a
valuable public service and have helped
to bring about this very interesting
debate that we're having this afternoon
I'm very forgetful I mean the point I
was making is given the other petitions
which are also on the parliaments
petition website just now which are
arguably more worldly and certainly have
more supporters in some cases why is it
the Sky News have not given them any
coverage or reported on those petitions
whilst have given almost hourly coverage
to their own campaign well I suggest
probably because it's their own campaign
off but but it's an extremely it's an
extremely valid point that a lot of the
issues that he mentioned are are issues
that are worthy of more coverage in the
news and I hopefully his remarks will
have brought those campaigns to the
attention of broadcasters and that they
will receive more coverage in the future
he did say that that he thought that
debates provided very little additional
information for voters and again I would
disagree because the Hansard Society
report actually does indicate as I said
in an intervention on the Honourable
gentleman who introduced the debate does
actually indicate that the general
public say that they've they find
debates a very very valuable way of
gaining information to help them decide
how to vote indeed amongst the most
important ways that they can gain
information in helping them decide how
to vote he went on also to talk about
the
SMP the the SNP leaders role in the
debates and whether or not a voter from
Cornwall would be interested in what the
leader of the SNP had to say and in fact
of course in fact I think he said they
wouldn't be able to vote for the leader
of the SNP well of course nobody in
Scotland would be able to vote for the
leader of the SNP I'm either because the
lead of the SNP was not candidate in the
general election in the debate so it
does raise interesting points as to who
should be participated in debates and
whether those who participate in debates
should be the leaders of political
parties or should be the leaders
operative groups who are hoping to gain
election to the House of Commons and I
you know it's a moot point but it's it
is a it is a valid point it's the same
is true even though obviously the leader
of the SNP would be extremely important
to Scottish voters it isn't the case
that they would have an opportunity to
vote for her in a general election in
Scotland and then the Honourable
gentleman from North Devon who always
speaks with a great deal of expertise in
in broadcasting matters because of his
previous career with the BBC ask the
question how could leaders be compelled
to attend if it were the case that we
were to pass a bill as well as the one
envisaged by the Honorable gentleman for
Wellingborough which would say that that
political party leaders had to
participate in these debates well I
think as others have pointed out it's
not unreasonable I think for us to
expect the leaders of political parties
who have ambitions to become prime
minister to comply with the law and I
would be I think it would be
extraordinary I'm not suggesting we
should have any draconian penalties for
anyone refusing to comply with the law
at all but it would be extraordinary if
the leader of a political party who was
a potential candidate to be prime
minister of this country sought to not
comply with what is a perfectly
reasonable law to get them to
participate in a in an essential element
of the democratic process as judged by
this Parliament so I think
that's a little bit of a red herring
really I think they they would turn up
by virtue of the very fact that it was
the law that they should participate and
neither is it unreasonable that such a
law should be considered and potentially
reached the statute book and he did
however I think make a very interesting
and valid point about how relevant our
TV debates in this age of social media
and that they were old-fashioned that in
a sense we're asking a question that is
no longer particularly pertinent and
perhaps would have been much more
relevant thirty or forty years ago well
I think and I do bow to his expertise
about television but I actually think
that we're linear television still hits
home is in the big live event type of
television whether that is you know the
X Factor or whether that is a sporting
event all whether it is a participation
of political leaders at the time of a
general election when the nation's
attention is turned to who will be
governing the country for the next five
years I think at that time a live
television linear type of event actually
is still highly relevant is still of
interest to the public and would be
supplemented massively by activity on
social media I think that's true and
obviously social media has a huge role
to play in modern elections and this is
an area that we need to look at in more
detail the whole issue of social media
Facebook and other other types of
platforms which now have a major
influence on our politics so I just want
to say a few brief words about that
because we are supporting the in broad
terms that the campaign that there
should be some sort of independent means
for making sure that TV debates take
place between the leaders at general
elections and I think the reason we're
doing so and I'd say this to the
Minister is that she does have the
opportunity as a minister to try and
make some sense of the current
complicated electoral law that we have
is voluminous our electoral law it's
fragmented
it poses problems for election
administrators traitors for campaigners
for voters for policymakers there are 40
acts of parliament mr. Davis and over a
hundred and seventy statutory
instruments relating to our electoral
legal framework and some of those
provisions go back into the 19th century
and it's widely accepted by those who
are involved in administering and
competing in elections such as the
Electoral Commission the Association of
election administrators that fundamental
reform of electoral laws needed but the
government hasn't really listened about
that in 2016 in February 2016 in fact so
that's nearly three years ago the Law
Commission published its interim report
calling for the current laws governing
elections to be rationalized into a
single consistent legislative framework
governing all elections and the
government has yet to respond to that
and it's nearly three years since the
Law Commission published that report so
I would encourage the government to do
that and to look again and respond to
that report and also to look at and I've
mentioned this previously the 2018 audit
of political engagement by the Hansard
society which found that among different
sources of news and information
respondents used to inform their
decision-making at the general election
in 2017 that party leaders debates and
political interviews those two things
were deemed the most important ways in
which they were able to make up their
minds seventy-four percent of those who
use them said that the party leaders
debates and political interviews were at
least fairly important in their
decision-making so I think there is a
need for a wider reform of electoral law
and within that the issue of TB debate
TV debates should be included my own
party leader has said and in response to
this campaign and I quote I welcome any
move that will guarantee general
election debates so that voters can hear
directly from those putting themselves
forward to lead the country and I think
that's a welcome statement but the Prime
Minister unfortunately hasn't matched
and I think that's a shame she said in
response when speaking to sky about this
the next general election isn't until
2022 there's plenty of time to think
about those issues at that time well in
fact that is exactly the time where they
won't be plenty of time to think about
these issues
mr. Davis now is the time to think about
them we may not immediately be able to
solve the issues but now is the time
when we should be actually thinking you
know across parties about the best way
to to handle the seating issue because
if we get to 2022 and we start thinking
about it we'll have the same old chewing
and throwing and shenanigans and
jiggery-pokery that we have seen
recently in relation to the discussions
about the possibility of leaders debates
over brexit now whatever we think about
the merits of that it's a different
question to whether leaders should
debate at a general election whatever we
think of the merits of that the truth is
how these sorts of arguments come about
ah and this has happened you know over
probably over governments you know going
back some considerable time as something
like this and in fact I know exactly how
this one came about because number ten
went to Tom Newton done at the Sun and
said we want to we need a page Li for
the Prime Minister on breaks it
parameters in trouble embrace it we need
a page lead if you need a page leading
the Sun that doesn't you don't you don't
get that for nothing so they said in
return well what can you give us what
can you give us as an exclusive as a
scoop in old-fashioned terms for giving
you a page Li front page lead in the Sun
and of course the answer was well we'll
say that the Prime Minister is in favor
of challenging the leader of the
opposition to a debate on brexit in the
full knowledge that that was never going
to happen unless there had been some
groundwork done unless they've been some
discussion between parties unless the
other parties who have an interest in
this as the Honorable gentleman rightly
pointed out from the SNP had an
opportunity to have an input as well it
was it was not going to happen on those
sorts of terms but that's how these
things come about and really that is a
pretty shabby process mr. Davis and if
we had an independent properly
independent process then we could get
rid of all of the the the jiggery-pokery
and election debates and actually get
down to concentrating on trying to
present our policies effectively to the
electorate so I'd like to challenge
finally the minister to perhaps go a
little bit further than the government
have done so far and to at least
entertain the possibility of supporting
the kind of measure that's being
proposed by Sky News the kind of measure
that's been proposed by her honourable
friend and the kind of measures that
we're talking about in the opposition
and other parties have also supported to
perhaps find a consensus for a way
forward to ensure that these debates can
happen and not to wait till 22 when it's
far too late it's an absolute pleasure
to serve under your chairmanship and
earlier on of course that of mr. Sharma
can I first of all thank both the
petitioners and the Honourable member
for città store and nuki for creating
this petition bringing it here today and
articulating its arguments for the
purposes of the of the debate and I
think the Honourable member put the
arguments in their original position in
a capable way and I'm glad that he did
that for us today and I'd like to thank
both his committee that he represents
and of course those members of the
public who signed that petition I do
very very much agree and I'd like to say
this at the outset I do very very much
agree that TV debates are that useful
democratic exercise that many here today
have said that they are an outline that
they that they can be and they allow the
electorate to reflect on the choices
that they wish to make at an election
there is plenty of academic literature
as well as surveys confirming that
members of the public do indeed find TV
election debates informative and
engaging they can also and I think this
is very important to to me in my work as
the elections minister they cannot say
serve as one of those important tools
that engages people who don't perhaps
normally engage in politics to every so
often come together and have a think
about an election and the big choice
that's represented by that election I
really value that as I know do many
member
on remembers here in this chamber today
so there's no dispute or I don't think
between us that this is an important
matter but I think what we are here to
talk about is how is the best way to go
about it and that is what I'd like to
focus my remarks upon today I'm not I'm
not persuaded that mandating television
election debates is the way to achieve
that very very important goal I'd like
to thank all on Raw and regional members
who have contributed today in in summary
form we heard the case against put by
the Honourable member for Roxburgh and
North Devon and the the case for put by
the members support for Stroud
Wellingborough I think reluctantly they
honor member for Blakeley and Broughton
and then of course the two other front
benches here today the VAT of the SNP
and the Labour Party I do
of course note the unremember for
Wellington Wellingborough as private
member's bill and I look forward to no
doubt continuing this discussion with
him when that comes before the house and
I'd like to reassure him and other
members night I don't in any way stand
here to dismiss these arguments I stand
a to engage with them but the question
in front of me I think is well is this
the best way of achieving more people
engaging with our democracy I'm going to
make five key points around the idea of
legislating to mandate T V election
debates not about TV election debates in
their own virtue but legislating to
mandate them which is of course what we
have in front of us in the petitions
case so first of all I'm going to I'm
going to to begin with the points that T
V election debates have of course
already happened under their own steam
in the last three general elections
without having had to be mandatory under
election law and indeed the Honourable
member for Edinburgh East made this
point himself he said he rightly says
that debates happen all the time and
they happen five ways in in Scotland and
indeed they do happen many ways
throughout our elections in recent
history and I would say and I'll draw on
the Honourable member for Stroud's words
he said well the genie was out of the
bottle since
ten well yes it is and the genie
actually has already come out of the
bottle without having needed to have
been legislated for so my first point
really will be this that the current
arrangements actually between political
parties and broadcasters work they
already give rise to election debates
and that is bolstered by the regulatory
framework set of course by the
independent regulator Ofcom I'll come on
to these points in more detail
I will secondly put the argument that
attendance at TV debates is actually a
matter for political parties rather than
the law I want to develop bad arguments
a little I'll also I'll also bring into
this the way that there are many other
campaign mediums used by parties to
convey their messages and by voters to
choose how they get their information
and that we shouldn't prioritize one
above others we do need to consider some
matters about implementation and I'll
come on to that and I also want to just
briefly in imposing refer to some of the
other evidence that we have seen here in
Parliament mr. Davis for example
including select committees on this
matter so let me start first of all with
with this point around debates happening
already and and they indeed they do and
members here today have have capably
covered how this has happened since 2010
now under the current arrangements that
has happened by agreement between
political parties and broadcasters and
indeed broadcasters collaborate between
themselves or on the key factors to to
make it happen so TB election debates
have been successfully delivered with
decisions about format location
participation have all been settled and
crucially the public have benefitted
from and no doubt enjoyed the results I
put today that experienced broadcasters
including sky but also including other
broadcasters as well are well-placed to
continue to make such decisions and it's
not right to instead take that off them
and put that into law I think it's also
helpful actually that different
broadcasters are able to choose to bring
their own distinct
to election debates and I think that we
come very close in what we're discussing
today to matters of editorial
independence which we should of course
leave with broadcasters and indeed their
own ability to organize and deliver TV
election debates especially given that
we are talking here about the costs
residing within that we and one might
argue that the costs and the delivery
therefore should stay in the same in the
same place moving on to a second
argument and I said earlier on that
these debates are a matter for political
parties to choose to do now I don't say
that lightly I say that actually in full
consideration but it is then for the
electorate to choose as of course this
is what elections are about it is for
the electorate to choose a political
party that has capably communicated to
them something that they liked to hear
that is the fundamental nature of a
choice at at an election voters reward
political parties who are aligned to
their own priorities and who communicate
that well and successfully failing to
effectively communicate your priority to
a voter is unlikely to lead to electoral
success I don't think I need to break
that to any colleagues here in the room
today that is of course the whole point
of elections and so I say from that
point of view again though there isn't a
need I don't think for government legal
legislative rather intervention here
when in fact voters interests and indeed
party's interests are very closely
aligned on this point in a way that has
already worked I want us to bring in
some points here about Ofcom and the
broadcasting code because when we're
discussing the current framework it is
important of course to consider the
framework that TV election debates would
have to adhere to
Ofcom as the independent communications
regulator sets the standards already for
programs on TV and radio and their code
contains rules which apply to all
broadcasters who are licensed by Ofcom
and that ensures that news in whatever
form is reported with do
partiality accuracy and fair prominence
of views and opinions crucially it also
includes specific rules that apply
during election periods around
impartiality and that includes the
requirement for GU weight to be given to
the coverage of parties and independent
candidates I think we can continue to
take confidence in that regulatory
framework in that it both supports the
editorial independence of broadcasters
and has already demonstrated it is able
to deliver fair and politically neutral
television election debates now I'd add
to that that an independent broadcasting
system is in itself a democratic
function that we enjoy in this society
we are very lucky to have that and and
again I say that government intervention
risks undermining that independence of
the broadcasters and of Ofcom now I do
note that the argument has been put
today that this could be achieved
through an independence debate this
commission and I'll come back to that
point in just a second mr. Davis let me
first just deal with this idea of
whether we should privilege one
campaigning medium over another
should we campaign telly over other ways
of communicating with each other night
and I'm not convinced on this point
there are of course many mediums used by
political parties to convey their
message to members of the public before
a general election and as every other
time of the year as well and which the
public demands and as I said earlier on
this is absolutely a matter a two-way
matter between what public the public
the ways that the public choose to
choose to get their information and ask
to have information and ways in which
parties can can respond to that this is
very much that two-way process between
parties and the public of themselves I
mean I for one am quite a fan of the
good old fashioned political canvassing
method mr. Davis I was out there in the
very chilly cold Norwich weather on
Saturday morning myself knocking on
doors back to work in the New Year as I
hope every member in this room also was
but that is another way of getting in
touch with voters and Who am I
to say that television is any better or
worse than that I don't don't attempt to
make that judgment call and I am
skeptical of the call here today that
suggests that any one medium is in
itself better than another yes of course
does she not accept that we already
discriminate in legislation possibly in
favor possibly against depending on your
point of view the electronic media we
demand that they provide a platform for
party political broadcasts and we demand
that they balance their the different
views during general election campaign
we do not apply that to any other forms
of media so there is already a
separation and so it would not be really
changing the legislative framework very
much to say that they should provide a
platform for debates I agree and I
disagree I and I respect the way that he
has has tried to bring that point to
bear here but I think the particular
point of detail that he has just chosen
to use there is actually about when you
do use any one medium you make sure
there is impartiality within that and I
think that is admirable that's where I
agree with him but I think where I
disagree with what I've just heard him
say is this
we should further entrench the choice of
any one medium over another and let me
put this let me put this in in a
generational sense for him television
broadcasts are quite simply losing favor
with a younger generation as their
source of news why should we legislate
at this point in time for a medium that
is not necessarily going to remain a
favored medium amongst those who will
become who indeed already are and then
will become more so the voters of the
elections to come very happy to
substantiate that you look at the way
that news consumption is going in the UK
and you could find a report by Ofcom
referring to 2018 alone where 52% of 16
24 year-olds used Facebook as their news
sauce walas whilst only 39% used BBC one
that report found that that age group
was more likely to get their news from
social media posts rather than directly
from news organizations and so in the
face of that technological shift I
remain unconvinced that the case is made
for us privileged in one form that one
might almost argue had it had a heyday
with with Richard Nixon in the last
century why she went privileged to that
form over this wire sorry I say Nixon of
course I suppose has already been
covered so it was thought that Kennedy
won the debate but that's the very point
of it that is that is actually it is a
matter of history there and really what
we ought to be looking for if we
legislate at all is of course to the
Future rather than to the
a new key which is that you know here we
stand today having a debate in
Parliament in itself a form of political
debate a form of debate on on political
policy and we don't expect this only to
be covered on the TV although it will
capably be in and I'm glad for that I'm
certainly do support the use of of TV in
Parliament and and the accountability
that we can provide by being on camera
as we do our work but we also expect
that social media carries part of that
way we also might well expect that
there'll be some people who prefer to
read about these proceedings in the
written words all of these are valid
ways of people getting their information
and we shouldn't privilege one over
another fourthly let me come on to some
points about implementation and I just
wanted to I wanted to bring these
together and refer to a few that had
been made through the debate as well
first of all and this proposal would of
course require primary legislation and I
note the points that have already been
been made that if we do anticipate a
general election as far away as 2022
which is of course of course the case
then we have time to to try to to look
at this and get this right well even on
that time scale there are other pressing
priorities that the public ask of us in
legislation which I suspect may come
before this yes of course I understand
the minister is making a very strong
government speech of which I agree with
very little I have to say but mr. Davis
I'm here to help the Minister as always
it does not it does record primary
legislation but not government
legislation that's why the private
member bill root and all I'm going to
ask the minister to do is would she
allow that debate to get a fair hearing
no objecting no for the bustering no
putting up people to stop it
let's have the debate in the boat would
she would she be open-minded to that I
thank you mr. Davis I can only hope mr.
Davis that the honourable gentleman's
and flattery of me today extends
knowing that I am a friend of parliament
and I look forward to Parliament having
its own opportunity to make that debate
when that time comes I will make no
further comment on what should be the
passage or otherwise of of that bill but
but what I am doing here today and I
hope I hope it is is welcome is trying
to go into some of the arguments that do
reasonably pertain to the proposal that
we've got in front of us I think it's
actually a the least courtesy we can we
should give to any petition in fact
actually we should give it a proper
going over with the arguments that we
think relate to it and that's what I'm
trying to do so I just want to call the
houses attention really to to the way
that of course this would require
primary legislation to do that isn't to
a penny it does require some
prioritization about what we choose to
do in primary legislation and that is
the part of the electoral law framework
that would have to be looked at if we
wanted to do this and the Honourable
member actually on the on the labor
front bench has already made the point
that election law is complex it is
thought by many to be fragmented and and
unwieldy and indeed it is agit I mean
this is absolutely the case he's right
to say that there are parts of the
election law that relate to the 19th
century I've already made the point that
I'm not convinced we should add another
piece in that arguably relates to the
20th century let alone in the 21st but
he is right to say that election law is
a very complicated matter and I and I
don't yet see the argument for adding
this to it in in primary legislation per
se let me go on to let me go on to
another aspect of what it means to put
something into law and this was already
referred to I think by the Honourable
member for North Devon in particular I
died I also share his concern that this
is this it's not I don't think likely to
be a priority for law enforcement to
enforce somebody to come along and manet
end a debate it you know effectively to
make somebody a criminal for not taking
part in a debate and to somebody for
example such as
Jahna gentleman from cardiff who
suggests that he doesn't want to add any
penalties to this but still wants to see
it in law well I think that's not a very
strong position if you don't wish to
criminalize something somebody for
something you don't put it into law if
you think that a proposal stands on its
own just because it's reasonable and
virtuous well that's fine but in this
case you might look to the fact that it
happens already and needn't be made
mandatory in law you put something in
law if you want his chief constable and
mine to have to spend their time
thinking about it and I'm not
necessarily convinced that it is the
right thing to do to make members of
political parties into into criminals
for not participating in a TV debate or
indeed any other campaigning activity we
all also also also think to give a
thought to the electorate at this point
as well if participation in the debate
is compulsory well is going to be
watching them compulsory as well do we
and know in all seriousness the
honorable gentleman raises the laughs at
this point but it's a question that
follows if we privilege one campaign
medium in law a question follows that we
think it's important that people are
compelled to take part in the activity
that is what we do when we put something
into law now let me let me go on from
here then about to some points about
about using a quango to do this and
again the Honorable gentleman from North
Devon was not convinced for example that
an independent debates commissioned
woods would improve the current system
and I was very grateful actually toothed
honourable member for Blakeley and
Broughton who gave this thought as well
although he came down in in the end on
the other side all for the argument I
don't think that the having of a quango
and simply calling it independent is
necessarily the answer to every every
every policy question here and I and I
do want to put on a record that I think
it raises many questions that that are
as yet unresolved for example who would
appoint the members of such a body how
it would how it would function what
would happen if political parties or or
a and any figure involved in it disagree
suggested format these are all the
questions that would still have to be
bottom doubts if you if we went for an
independent debates Commission format on
a final note let me just bring into this
debate the other reports and reservist
that do exist on this matter because the
proposal for that independent body isn't
a new one in fact it's been addressed in
multiple reports including a 2014 Select
Committee on communications in the House
of Lords which published its findings on
broadcasting general election debates
and they found no substantial evidence
that an independent debates commission
should be set up to oversee election
debates indeed their report went on to
focus on recommendations instead for
broadcasters that do oversee two debates
such as making more use of the
opportunity to inform voters and
encouraging members of the public to be
more interested in the electoral process
there is also in addition to those
findings a very interesting piece of
work from Professor Charlie Beckett of
the London School of Economics who
published findings in 2015 that
highlighted that a formal regulatory or
legislative framework around TV election
debates is largely viewed as unrealistic
and undesirable he also raises again
some of these questions around such a
framework such as who would have the
final say and how it might be adaptable
to to evolution in the political
landscape so if I just draw my my
contribution to this debate to a close
and I and I thank our members mr. Davis
for giving me time to go go through the
arguments at some length I would again
like to thank petitioners first and
foremost and the member for central
still a new key for bringing this debate
here today and for allowing us to to
examine its arguments I think we have
heard a number of very good arguments on
the topic although mainly I think they
are they focused too to my ear on the
way that TV debates are good and helpful
in themselves rather than necessarily
the ins and outs of
waiting for them to be to be the way
forward um if we were to consider a
change in electoral law I think we would
have to I think we would have to be able
to see some improvements in in some of
those arguments before going to the
extent of making them mandatory and
adding to an area of law that is already
very complex and precious um I do think
that participating in in TV election
debates should should continue to be a
matter for political parties and I think
we should continue to see that that is a
two-way relationship with the
encouragement of voters the delivery of
such debates I think should remain in
the hands of broadcasters and indeed of
other publishers and indeed of the
public themselves in social media and
the other media of the future I'm a very
passionate promoter of people's
involvement in democracy and very
honored mr. Davis to be that steward of
our electoral system but it's actually
that that draws me to conclude that we
should let people decide for themselves
what those formats ought to be of the
future rather than rather than privilege
in one format at this point in time I I
do
in conclusion entirely trust the British
people to be able to find the
information that suits them and make
their choices in elections and at
election times and that is what I hope
to see in the elections of the future
Thank You mr. Davis and I want to thank
all honourable members who have
participated in this debate I think it's
been a good debate it's been a a good
number of very thoughtful and well
presented contributions I would like to
again thank sky for their role in
bringing this petition forward that is
enabled to have this debate today I
think it's actually been right that we
have had this debate today this is an
issue that I think needs careful
consideration and hopefully today's
debaters has made a useful contribution
to that consideration going forward I
thank the Minister for
her response and laying out government's
position and although I'm sure many of
us will be disappointed we haven't
managed to persuade her to our way
thinking appreciate the way that she's
presented the government's position on
this the the point I would make is that
I do think that this is a matter that
really does need to be dealt with by way
of consensus within Parliament this is a
matter to do with our there's wider than
than the government's positions to do
with general elections and and our
democratic process and therefore I very
much welcome my honourable friend
the member for Wellingborough as private
member's bill and that will give us
another opportunity in in the relatively
near future to for Parliament to
consider this matter again and as has
been made hopefully that will enable
Parliament to express its view on this
and if it is such that that we should
formalize leaders debates then that will
give us the opportunity to do that and I
would simply make the point that I am
winding up that I think it is important
that we embrace all methods of engaging
the public in politics particularly at
the time of elections and I was very
thankful the Minister made clear that
she welcomes TV debates is not that
anyone is against TV debates it is a
matter of how we facilitate them I
continue to be of the view that I think
the current system doesn't really work
and the horse trading and towing or
throwing there goes on actually reflects
badly on this place and on the political
parties and actually formalizing it and
take it out of the hands of politicians
I think I still think would be a
positive way forward but hopefully today
has been a useful contribution to that
bait I'm sure it's one that will
continue in the coming months and years
and we certainly look forward to
discussing this again in the very near
future so thank you once again for
everyone for their contributions this
house is considered
two to eight five seven to relating to
an independent commission on televised
election debates as well as all of that
opinion say aye
the country no I think the eyes have it
the eyes have it order order
the proceeding has ended the proceeding
has ended the proceeding has ended the
proceeding has ended the proceeding has
ended the proceeding has ended the
proceeding has ended